[Music]
Well, fair trade or fair trade is a
first step, they become aware that
products are not born in the store where
they are bought, but rather they are and involve the work
of people who are behind it.
The greatest fear
that my children do not have a future  that
the one I had to give him a little
unemployed if he has eaten talks about his
dad
Juana meek the pen being in the
dark for me I like commerce because it
is an opportunity to implement
development to manage this of
all workers
with good working conditions  and
environmental
is not so bad
I imagined to improve my house like everyone
and then something to eat you are helping
not a person maybe a family
with a traditional that is managed
by the committee of workers of the
entity elected in a
democratic way awake  in you something that you
can be a leader to speak and express
decisions to me and give my opinion
when making a fair trade garment I
feel that he is valuing me he is
valuing my work and effort for me
it is the greatest joy as worked
[Music]